[Music]
finally there are some details about
Denzel Washington's role in Gladiator 2
director Ridley Scott is currently
celebrating box office success with
Napoleon and is now opening up about the
sequel to his classic 24 years after
Gladiator with Russell Crowe and Wen
Phoenix part two is to be released this
time Oscar nominated Paul mcow takes on
the starring role of Lucius the Foster
son of Wen Phoenix's character in the
predecessor he meets Denzel Washington
who plays a businessman Ridley Scott
describes the role in an interview with
deadline as follows a man who supplied
the Romans with weapons oil horses and
wine everything they needed but he also
had a dark past as a gladiator who was
captured in North Africa and eventually
fought his way to Freedom as a gladiator
he uses these experiences to now run a
stable of Gladiators himself the
character of Denzel Washington is more
powerful than some senators in Rome
although he tries to hide it but his
thirst for power is far from being
satisfied in addition to Paul mascal and
denel Washington the cast of Gladiator 2
is quite impressive the Mandalorian and
the last of a star Pedro Pascal is also
part of the team as is moonnight actress
May kamami in a further leading role
Fred hinger will play the young Emperor
geta as the villain from the previous
Gladiator Connie Nielsen and jaman hansu
return to their roles the movie is set
around 15 years after part one we are
looking forward to the theatrical
release of Gladiator 2 on November 22nd
[Music]